And then he was like, oh, do you ever come to New York? And I was like, yeah, all the time, which is totally a lie. And like, I gave you like extensive notes. I was like, we're not shooting this thing. It's not perfect. Well, you just, you never know when 7, recorded on December 26, 2020. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we wrap up our 2020 retro. Top five, counting down from five. And we can potentially, well, one of these in particular I mentioned to you could be a whole episode.
然后他说，哦，你经常去纽约吗？我说，对，经常去，这完全是个谎言。而且，我给你写了详细的意见，我说，这东西我们不能直接发，它还不完美。好吧，你就是，你永远不知道什么时候有7，录制于2020年12月26日。我叫康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，总结我们的2020年度回顾。前五名，从第五名开始倒数。我们可能，嗯，其中一个我特别提到过，对你来说可以成为整整一集。
But yeah, I'll just, I'll rattle through them and then we can. I'm going to bet that all five of them could be a whole episode. Probably not, but we'll see. We'll see. So number five was uh cpp con 2020 um definitely uh you know not not the same as you know being able to meet in person but uh cpp con virtual was it was still a lot of fun and we got to virtually meet online i don't think you attended um but there was there was still uh no no i was there i did one panel two panels i was around
但是，是的，我只，我快速过一遍，然后我们可以。我敢打赌这五个中的每一个都可以单独成为一集。可能不会，但我们走着瞧。我们走着瞧。所以第五名是嗯 cpp con 2020 嗯 绝对是 嗯 你知道的 不 完全一样 就像 能够亲自见面 一样 但是 嗯 cpp con 虚拟大会 仍然很有趣 我们得以在网上虚拟见面 我觉得你没有参加 嗯 但是 仍然有 嗯 不 不 我在那里 我参加了一个小组讨论 两个小组讨论 我在场
oh yeah yeah that's right that's right you were on a couple of the iso committee panels um yeah i didn't give a talk but uh i did some panels yeah but it was uh it was it was still nice to you know even though we couldn't in person meet virtually meet people. So yeah, CPP Kong 2020 was my number five. Uh, number four was, uh, the Prague ISO committee back in February, if I'm not mistaken. And specifically,
哦，对，对，没错，没错，你参加了几个ISO委员会的小组讨论，嗯，我没有做演讲，但我参加了一些小组讨论，但它仍然很好，你知道，尽管我们不能面对面见面，但可以虚拟见面。所以，是的，CPP Kong 2020是我的第五名。嗯，第四名是，嗯，2月份的布拉格ISO委员会，如果我没记错的话。具体来说，
you know, this is not ISO related exactly. Um, but we, I don't, well, so this could turn into a long episode again. I don't,
你知道，这不完全和ISO相关。嗯，但是我们，我不，好吧，所以这可能会再次变成一个很长的节目。我不想，
I can't recall why. Um, at some point you just like a light bulb went off in year ahead and you were like we got to make a video um and then we spent a day or two sort of it was primarily mostly you mostly you we got to give credit well no so and that's this is actually i meant to bring this question up earlier um was like you mentioned sort of that we needed to get our combined excitement out into the world. You know, when was the first time that you had that thought? Because potentially it was the recording of that video
我想不起来为什么了。嗯，在某个时刻，你就像脑子里灵光一闪，然后你说我们得拍个视频，然后我们花了一天左右的时间，主要是你，主要是你，我们得承认这一点，好吧，不，所以，其实我本来想早点提出这个问题，就是你提到过我们需要把我们共同的兴奋感传达给世界。你知道，你第一次有这种想法是什么时候？因为可能就是录制那个视频的时候，
because we would go and like fake interview these people. And one of the best moments was when we did it with John Lakos. And he had just finished his book, his new C++, you know, large scale infrastructure or architecture book. And he had a copy with him and we said, go get your, go get your copy of the book. And so we recorded the little bit of him holding his book. And then when we cut it into the episode, we made it look like he was just sort of constantly plugging his book, which was just hilarious. The idea of the video was it was supposed to be both like, you know, it's supposed to show people like a slice of what the committee meeting was like and commemorate C++20, show people what they should be excited about, but also be hilarious um i i recall that the idea came to me like when i was at night like when i was
因为我们会去假装采访这些人。最好的时刻之一就是我们采访John Lakos的时候。他刚刚完成他的书，他的新C++，你知道的，大规模基础设施或架构书。他随身带了一本，我们说，去拿你的，去拿你的那本书。所以我们录下了他拿着书的一小段。然后当我们把它剪辑到节目里时，我们让它看起来好像他一直在不断地宣传他的书，这太搞笑了。这个视频的创意本意是，既要向人们展示委员会会议的一角，纪念C++20，向人们展示他们应该对什么感到兴奋，同时也要非常搞笑，嗯，我记得这个想法是在我晚上的时候出现的，比如当我
sleeping and like i wrote it down um on a piece of paper but i think i think i felt the you know this was the meeting where we finalized c++ 20 i knew c++20 was going to be very significant. It was going to be the largest revision of C++ since C++11, you know, possibly, arguably even larger. And I felt, I always feel that I have a responsibility to help, you know, promote all the great work that we do on C++ and make sure that people know and are excited about what's coming. So I think it was partially that. But also partially I wanted to give people a deeper look into what the committee process was like and, you know, build more of a connection between, so that like regular C++ programmers could see what the committee members were like,
在睡觉时，我把它写在了一张纸上，但我想，我认为我觉得，你知道，这是我们敲定C++ 20的会议，我知道C++ 20将非常重要。它将是自C++ 11以来C++最大的版本更新，你知道，可能，可以说甚至更大。我觉得，我一直觉得我有责任帮助，你知道，宣传我们在C++上所做的所有伟大工作，并确保人们了解并对即将到来的一切感到兴奋。所以我觉得部分原因是这个。但也有部分原因是我希望让人们更深入地了解委员会的运作流程，你知道，建立更多的联系，以便普通的C++程序员能够看到委员会成员是什么样的，
what the people who actually make the standard are like. You know, we always, we do this Reddit trip report at the end of committee meetings. It's something that I started doing a few years ago and it's sort of grown into this thing. And I just sort of felt like this was like a natural extension of that. And like, we should have something special for, uh, for this meeting. And, and like, boy, that was, you know, we didn't realize that was going to be the last committee meeting we were going to have for a while, but it was a really great meeting. It was the largest committee meeting we've had. Um, uh, Hannah and Avast, who hosted it, us and Prague, were really great hosts. Yeah, they were fantastic hosts.
制定标准的人到底是什么样的。你知道，我们总是，我们在委员会会议结束时写Reddit的行程报告。这是我几年前开始做的事情，它现在已经发展成了这样。我只是觉得这就像是那个事情的自然延伸。而且，我们应该为这次会议准备一些特别的东西，而且，天哪，那是，你知道，我们没有意识到那将是我们一段时间以来能开的最后一次委员会会议，但那真的是一次非常棒的会议。那是我们举办过规模最大的委员会会议。嗯，汉娜和阿瓦斯特，他们主持了这次会议，我们在布拉格，真的是非常棒的主持人。是的，他们是非常棒的主持人。
Yeah. But I was very happy with how that video came together, that we were, it was the night of the reception. They threw a big reception to commemorate C++20. And like, I'd had this idea like a day or two days before the end of the meeting. And like, we wanted to show the video to the committee. But the thing I remember most was the last day, like the closing plenary, we weren't certain whether we wanted to play the video at the end for everybody um and so we we we went up to try to play it at the end of the plenary before everybody left and we were trying to hook it up and like we couldn't get the audio working and there was like a two or three minute period where like people were starting to leave and like we couldn't get the audio working and i was like i wasn't even sure if we should be playing it there it was just sort of on a hunch that i
是的。但我对那个视频的制作效果非常满意，那是招待会的那天晚上。他们举办了一个盛大的招待会来纪念C++20。而且，我在会议结束前的一两天就有了这个想法。而且，我们想把视频放给委员会看。但我印象最深的是最后一天，比如闭幕全体会议，我们不确定是否要在最后给每个人播放这个视频，所以我们去试着在全体会议结束、大家离开之前播放它，我们试图把它连上，但是我们没法让音频正常工作，大概有两三分钟的时间，人们开始离开，我们没法让音频正常工作，我甚至不确定我们是否应该在那里播放它，这只是凭直觉
said we should that somebody else actually i think said to us you should go up and play the video we were just going to post it online um and it wasn't clear whether we're going to actually be able to play it and then like the audio started working and we started playing it um and then like everybody just started paying attention everybody came back in and they absolutely loved it um and i was i was really glad that we were able to that that worked out that we were able to play it for everybody um because you know the people who work on the standard um it's sometimes it's a very thankless job um but you did an amazing job it was uh like you put that together in the span of like 24 hours and i don't think you slept or ate food much uh in that period of time i ate food and i was wired on caffeine but yeah i
我说我们应该播放，实际上我认为是另一个人对我们说，你应该上去播放这个视频，我们本来只是打算把它发布到网上，而且还不清楚我们是否真的能够播放它，然后音频开始工作了，我们开始播放它，然后每个人都开始关注，每个人都回来了，他们非常喜欢它，我真的很高兴我们能够做到这一点，能够为每个人播放它，因为你知道，那些致力于标准工作的人，有时这是一份非常吃力不讨好的工作，但你做得太棒了，这就像你在24小时内把它拼凑在一起，我猜你在那段时间里几乎没怎么睡觉或吃东西，我吃了东西，而且我靠咖啡因保持亢奋，但是的，我
was i was up for like i think 48 hours uh or 24 yeah it was it was a long period of time that i was up for yeah and like i gave you like extensive notes i was like we're not shipping this thing it's not perfect to be yeah to really to really explain you know where it's the morning of the final day and i've at that point you know i've been up for yeah i think at least 36 hours without sleep and i'm wired on like the whatever the prog version of coke zeros are i don't think they had coke zeros it was like pepsi or something because i'm not a big coffee drinker so if if I need caffeine, I go to like soda. And I think I have like a final draft, which has been edited heavily like three times.
我醒着大概有48小时，或者24小时，是的，我醒了很长一段时间，是的，而且我给你发了详细的意见，我说，我们不能发布这个东西，它还不够完美，是的，真的，真的要解释一下，你知道，那是最后一天早晨，在那之前，你知道，我已经有至少36小时没睡觉了，我靠着某种布拉格版本的零度可乐之类的东西保持亢奋，我不认为他们有零度可乐，好像是百事可乐之类的，因为我不怎么喝咖啡，所以如果我需要咖啡因，我就会喝苏打水。我想我有一份终稿，它已经被大量修改了大约三次。
And so I've sent it to I've sent it to Bryce that morning. And and then he's still I've got to got to tweak a couple of things. We got to get rid of the you know, this logo. And so, yes, it's you got a lot of credits on the executive producer, executive editor, et cetera, et cetera. We'll link it in the show notes for those that haven't seen. And then afterwards, we had a bet. And I don't remember the specifics of the bet, but we had some crazy bet on how many views the video was going to get. And then I had a hedge on the bet where I had a separate bet with another person about how few videos the views the video would get. I think the bet involved you buying like whoever won the bet between me and you had to take the other one to a very fancy sushi restaurant in San Francisco.
所以我在那天早上把它发给了布莱斯。然后他仍然，我得调整几件事。我们得去掉这个标志。所以，是的，你有很多名誉出品人、执行编辑等各种头衔。对于那些还没看过的人，我们会在节目简介中提供链接。然后在那之后，我们打了个赌。我不记得打赌的具体细节了，但我们打了一个疯狂的赌，赌这个视频会获得多少播放量。然后我对这个赌做了对冲，我和另一个人打了个单独的赌，赌这个视频的播放量会多么少。我想这个赌的内容是，我和你之间谁输了，谁就得请另一个去旧金山一家非常高档的寿司餐厅。
And I recall that I lost that bet and I still owe you that like that very expensive sushi dinner. Yeah, it got I can't remember the video got in the in the time slot that we had set the bet for. I think it got like 20 or 30,000 views. But I think the bet was that it had to be at the time my most viewed video, which was like 60,000 views or something like that. So it came close, but it did not. It did not make the cut, which was fine for 000 views or something like that so it came close but uh it did not it did not make the cut which was it's fine for me i get some free sushi yeah it was it was there was there was there was some combination of the bet out of the of the outcome the multiple bets that involved me having a having to uh get a mohawk and i was just glad that that
我记得我输了那个赌，我依然欠你那顿非常昂贵的寿司晚餐。是的，我记不得视频在那个时间段内获得了多少播放量。我想它获得了大约两万或三万次播放。但我想打赌的内容是，它必须是我当时播放量最高的视频，大约是六万次播放左右。所以很接近，但它没有达到。它没有达到标准，对我来说没关系，我能吃到一些免费的寿司。是的，在那里，多个打赌的结果有一种组合，涉及我不得不弄一个莫霍克发型，我只是很高兴那个结果没有发生。但总的来说，那是第四名。好吧，我们得，我说我要进行闪电快问快答，结果没有进行闪电快问快答。所以，第五名是CBP Con 2020，第四名是布拉格以及那个视频的拍摄和剪辑，还有采访大家，那真的很有趣。第三名是开始这个播客。关于这个，我想我们不需要多说。这太棒了。如果我们有超过五六集节目，它在榜单上的排名可能会更高。但是，是的，这是我们在这个年底刚刚开始做的事。
that outcome did not happen but yeah so that was that was number four all right we gotta i said i was gonna lightning uh lightning round these and and have not been lightning rounding them so uh yeah number five was cbp con 2020 number four was the prog and the the filming and sort of editing of that video and getting to interview folks that was that was a lot of fun uh number three is starting this podcast. I don't think we have to say much about that. This has been a blast. It would probably be higher on the list if we had more than five or six episodes. But yeah, this is sort of, we just started at this tail end of the year.
第二名，这个我觉得真的可以单独成为一集。在新冠疫情真正爆发之前，二月底，这是我做的最后一件事。我订了一张去纽约的机票，和亚瑟·惠特尼（Arthur Whitney）一起度过了两三天，他可能是一个你从未听过名字的人，也是这个播客的许多听众从未听过名字的人。亚瑟·惠特尼是肯尼斯·艾弗森（Kenneth Iverson）的门生，这简直可以引出另一个播客。所以肯尼斯·艾弗森，对于那些从过去的节目中没有记住的人来说，是APL的发明者和APL的创建者。他有一个门生，后来发明了一种名为K的语言。并且已经有了八个不同的版本。然后K衍生出另外两种语言。它的最新版本是Shakti，而Q是K的后代，具体来说来自K4。
Number two, this is the one that I really think could be a whole episode. Before COVID had really taken off, at the end of February, this was the last time I did anything. I had booked a flight down to New York and I spent, uh, two or three days with Arthur Whitney, who is probably a name you've never heard of and a name that many listeners of this podcast have never heard of. Arthur Whitney is Kenneth Iverson's protege, which is like enter the whole other podcast. So Kenneth Iverson, for those that have not remembered
我给他发了一封电子邮件，想通个电话聊聊，然后他说，哦，你有时会来纽约吗？我说，对，经常来，这完全是个谎言。然后我花了几天的，嗯，并不是每天聊八个小时。但我们吃了晚饭，聊了几次。他的故事绝对是现象级的，将成为我未来关于APL演讲的一部分。第一名是开始我五月份创建的编程语言虚拟聚会，作为给自己找点事做的一种方式，也是为了在阅读书籍等内容时对自己负责。我们一直在学习《计算机程序的构造和解释》。
from the past episodes, is the inventor of APL and the creator of APL. And he had a protege that went on to invent a language called K. And there's been eight different versions of that. And then K spawned sort of two other languages. The most recent version of it is Shakti, and then Q is a descendant of K, specifically from K4.
这真的很棒，就像这个播客一样。有一个核心群体，我们在周一见面，我们正处于一个章节的尾声。我们在第5.3章，它一直到5.5章。所以我们快完成了。是的，在疫情期间和那群人虚拟见面，
I had sent him an email about having a phone call to chat, and then he was like, oh, do you ever come to New York? And I was like, yeah, all the time, which is totally a lie. And then I spent a couple days, yeah, not for eight hours a day chatting with him. But we had dinner and we talked a few times. And his story is absolutely phenomenal and will be a part of the APL talk that I give in the future. And the number one is starting the Programming Languages Virtual Meetup that I started back in May as sort of something to give myself to do and also to hold myself accountable when reading books and stuff. And we've been working our way through the structure and interpretation of
感觉真是太棒了，因为是的，我们不再能亲自去参加聚会了，所以能够和大家在虚拟中聊天真好，是的，这就是我的前五名榜单。你今年不是也在NVIDIA开始工作的吗？你是什么时候开始在NVIDIA工作的？我开始，所以就是这样。五名榜单。你今年不是也在NVIDIA开始工作的吗？你是什么时候开始在NVIDIA工作的？我开始，所以就是这样。其实，有几件事我觉得，哦，这绝对是榜单第一。然后我意识到，
computer programs. And that has just been, it's been a blast the same way that this podcast has. There's a core group of individuals that we meet on Mondays and we're at the tail end of a chapter. We're on chapter 5.3 and it goes to 5.5. So we're almost done. And yeah, meeting with that group of folks
那些事情发生在2019年。所以我在2019年10月开始在NVIDIA工作。我们可以做，好吧，所以我觉得的一件事，哦，对，那绝对是第一名。然后意识到那是2019年，我们的贝尔法斯特晚宴，我确信你对它有着非常美好的回忆。那将永远是我职业生涯和生活中的亮点之一。美好的时光。是的，那确实是，整个那段时间，整个2019年秋天，我们在会议上度过的时间比在家里还要多。那很好。那是一段美好的时期。
just like virtually in the pandemic has been awesome um because yeah we don't really get to go to meetups in person anymore um so it's nice to be able to chat with folks virtually and uh and yeah that's my that's my top five list didn't you also uh didn't you also start it in video this year when did you start it i started so that's the thing five list. Didn't you also start at NVIDIA this year? When did you start at NVIDIA? I started, so that's the thing. I actually, there was a couple things that I was like, oh, that's top of the list for sure. And then I realized that that was,
是的。一个有趣的小冷知识。所以在我们推特个人资料的横幅照片上，现在有一张我们在玩拼字游戏的照片。但原照片仍然在旁边，是一张布莱斯和我在——哦，我一下子记不起那个公园的名字了。我妹妹会很失望的。但她不听这个播客，所以没关系。我们在都柏林的某个公园里，因为布莱斯和我——好吧，我去拜访了我住在都柏林的妹妹，我三个住在都柏林的妹妹之一。我去帮忙。而布莱斯不请自来。然后我们去了这个公园，我们看到了一些鹿。布莱斯带了额外的鞋子和袜子，因为显然这就是布莱斯会做的事。
those things happened in 2019. So I started in NVIDIA at October, 2019. We could do, well, so the one thing that I thought, oh yeah, that's number one for sure. And then realized it was, uh, 2019 was our, um, Belfast dinner, which I'm sure you have very fond memories. That will forever be like one of my career and life highlights. Um, good times. Yeah, that was, it was a, that whole, that whole, the the whole fall of 2019 where we spent more time at conferences than we did at like our home. That was good. That was a good that was a good period.
而我没有。我带了额外的鞋子和袜子，而你没有。在坐公交车回贝尔法斯特的路上，谁的脚很冷？我的脚很冷。我只记得走过这个泥泞的公园，然后，你突然掏出这双新袜子。我当时就想，谁会干这种事？好吧，你永远不知道什么时候会需要一双备用袜子。得学会旅行。
Yeah. Fun, fun trivia fact. So on the on our like little banner photo on our Twitter profile is now there's a photo of us at the Scrabble game. But the original photo, which is still there off to the side, is a picture of Bryce and I under – oh, I'm not going to remember the park off the top of my head. My sister will be disappointed. But she doesn't listen to this podcast, so that's fine. We were at a park in Dublin because Bryce and I – well, I had gone to visit my sister who lives in Dublin, one of my three sisters that lives in Dublin. And I went to help. And Bryce invited himself. And then we went to this park and we saw some deer. And Bryce brought extra shoes and socks because apparently that's what Bryce does.
好吧，让我想想。我的顶级，好吧，好吧，我有一个列表。它是无序的，可能包含五件事，也可能不包含。所以，很明显，你知道，排在比较靠前的是我们发布了C++20，我要说的是，这是C++自C++11以来最具影响力的版本更新。所以我们在2月份的布拉格会议上敲定了它，然后它经历了发布的各种阶段，大约一周前被ISO正式发布。还有一些其他关于C++的事情。所以在布拉格会议上，蒂图斯·温特斯（Titus Winters），他曾担任C++委员会的库演进主席。库演进基本上就是库设计小组。
And I did not. I brought extra shoes and socks and you did not. And whose feet were very cold on the bus ride back to Belfast? Mine were. I just remember walking through this marshy park, and then afterwards, you just whip out this new pair of socks and shit. I'm just like, who does this? Well, you never know when you might need an extra pair of socks. Gotta learn to travel.
这里没有任何多余的文本。
Yeah, let's see. My top, well, okay, I got a list. It's unordered and it may or may not be five things. So, obviously, you know, pretty high up there is the fact that we published C++20, which is, I'm going to say, the most impactful revision of C++ and C++11, at least. So we finalized it at the Prague meeting in February, and then it went through all the various stages of publication, and it was officially published by ISO like a week or so ago. And there's some other C++ things. So at the Prague meeting, Titus Winters, who had been the library evolution chair on the C++ committee. Library evolution is basically the library design group.
结束。
He stepped down and I became the new library evolution chair. And it was an interesting time to take on the job because we had this plan for there was going to be a transition period. And then that all got scrapped by the fact that the pandemic hit and we didn't have a summer meeting or a fall meeting. So it was sort of a trial by fire. And I'm very, very grateful that Herb Sutter had the wisdom to suggest that, you know, maybe chairing shouldn't just be a one-person thing. And so he suggested, well, you should have a co-chair, a vice chair, Fabio. And then I sort of took that to the extreme where I recruited another vice chair. And then I brought on some other people to help.
他卸任了，我成为了新的库演进委员会主席。接手这项工作是一个有趣的时刻，因为我们有一个过渡期的计划。然而，由于大流行爆发，我们既没有夏季会议也没有秋季会议，这个计划全部泡汤了。所以这有点像烈火中的考验。我非常非常感激 Herb Sutter 具有远见，建议说，你知道的，担任主席或许不应该只是一个人的事。因此他建议，好吧，你应该有一个共同主席、一个副主席，即法比奥（Fabio）。然后我把这个想法推到了极致，我又招募了另一位副主席。接着我又请了一些其他人来帮忙。
And so now we have this whole library evolution leadership team, which is great because we get to spread the load, makes us a lot more effective. So I've been very, I think that's the best thing that we've done in library evolution has been this notion of not just having one person in charge, but having a leadership team. And there were also some exciting stuff that we did at NVIDIA. So we launched the NVIDIA HPC SDK, which I work on. We launched NVC++, which is our new C++ compiler that has some very cool features like GPU accelerated C++ parallel algorithms.
所以现在我们有了整个库演进领导团队，这太棒了，因为我们可以分担工作量，让我们变得高效得多。因此我一直认为，我们在库演进中所做的最好的一件事就是这个概念：不只是让一个人负责，而是拥有一个领导团队。我们在英伟达也做了一些令人兴奋的事情。我们推出了英伟达 HPC SDK，这也是我参与开发的项目。我们推出了 NVC++，这是我们新的 C++ 编译器，它具有一些非常酷的功能，比如 GPU 加速的 C++ 并行算法。
It's kind of funny. Before I was at NVIDIA, I was at Lawrence Berkeley National Lab. And one of the main things I was working on there was getting the C++ parallel algorithms into C++. And so I was working on writing the spec. And then the spec spec got in then I left Lawrence Berkeley and I went to NVIDIA where my like first job was like hey go implement this spec so I got to write the spec I then got to I got paid to implement and my team also shipped our heterogeneous C++ standard library this year, the first release of that. And yeah, I think that's pretty much it. Oh, and my team sort of like doubled in size, which has been pretty exciting.
这挺有意思的。在加入英伟达之前，我在劳伦斯伯克利国家实验室工作。我在那里从事的主要工作之一就是将 C++ 并行算法引入 C++ 中。因此我当时在参与编写规范。然后规范被采纳了，接着我离开了劳伦斯伯克利，去了英伟达，我的第一份工作基本上就是“嘿，去实现这个规范吧”。所以我不仅有机会编写规范，后来还拿到了报酬去实现它。我的团队今年还发布了我们的异构 C++ 标准库，这是该库的第一个版本。是的，我想差不多就是这样。哦，我的团队规模差不多翻了一番，这非常令人兴奋。
We've hired some pretty awesome people. We've now got a really great team working on all of our open source libraries, and I'm really proud of all the work they're doing. Yeah, NVIDIA is, we sort of have alluded to this before on past episodes, but we more and more are headed in the direction of becoming an open source company, which, as you have remarked, is not historically what NVIDIA is known for. Yeah, but you and I both work at parts of the company where we pretty much exclusively work on open source stuff.
我们招聘了一些非常优秀的人才。现在我们有了一个非常棒的团队，致力于我们所有的开源库，我为他们所做的工作感到无比自豪。是的，英伟达……我们在过去的节目中曾暗示过这一点，但我们正越来越朝着成为一家开源公司的方向发展，正如你所说的那样，这在历史上并不是英伟达的知名标签。是的，不过你和我都在公司的部门工作，我们几乎专职从事开源相关的工作。
Yeah, which is, I absolutely love it. I mean, there's many, many reasons it's awesome, but one of the reasons is I can talk about everything I do. I mean, you can go and look at my commits and what I do for work and what I get paid for. So if I wanted to start Twitch streaming my day job, I technically could do that. I'm not sure how my picks would feel about it. But if I wanted to become a Twitch streamer and just stream my work, I think that would be totally okay. Well, don't worry.
是的，我绝对喜欢这样。我的意思是，这有很多很多的理由，其中一个原因就是我可以谈论我所做的一切。我的意思是，你可以去查看我的提交记录以及我为工作所做的事情和获得报酬的项目。所以如果我想开始在 Twitch 上直播我的日常工作，从技术上讲我是可以做到的。我不确定我的挑剔者们会对此作何感想。但如果我想成为一名 Twitch 主播并只直播我的工作，我认为这完全没问题。好吧，别担心。
None of your picks have enough time to have listened through to the end of this episode. That's true. They've got much better things to do. Yeah. All right. All of that being said. So what are you excited about for next year? What are you looking forward to in 2021?
你们的挑剔者中没有人有足够的时间听完这一集的结尾。确实如此。他们有更好的事情要做。是的。好吧。话虽如此。那么，你对明年有什么期待？你在 2021 年最期待什么？
2021. Well, I have a document, a sort of goals document. Of course you do. Of course you do. And there's a section within my document of broad categories, which has seven bullet points or six. Some of them can't be talked about. But yes, so Meetup is one of them to continue to do that. So we're wrapping up structure and interpretation of computer programs
2021 年。嗯，我有一份文档，类似于目标文档。你当然有。你当然有。我的文档中有一个关于广泛类别的部分，里面有七个或六个要点。其中一些不能公开谈论。但是，是的，Meetup 就是其中之一，会继续做下去。所以我们正在收尾《计算机程序的构造和解释》
and we'll either be starting concepts and techniques, CTM, whatever that stands for, concepts, techniques of modeling for computer programs. Then obviously, you know, my day job is awesome and going to be continuing to work on CUDF, which is the GPU version of Pandas, which is, it's honestly, it's the story of how I sort of landed there quasi thanks to you. And then how I have post landing on this team at NVIDIA have fallen in love with APL.
接下来我们要么开始《计算机程序的概念与技术》（CTM，无论它代表什么），即计算机程序的建模概念与技术。然后很明显，你知道的，我的日常工作很棒，并且将继续从事 CUDF 的开发，它是 Pandas 的 GPU 版本，说实话，这要归功于你，我才某种程度上阴差阳错地落脚于此。而在英伟达的这个团队落脚之后，我又爱上了 APL。
It is a very, very fortuitous thing. I won't go into the details, but basically, Kudief and Pandas are essentially descendants of APL. Not many people are aware of that, but APL, one of the children languages is J. J influenced Wes McKinney
这是一个非常非常幸运的巧合。我不细说细节了，但基本上，Kudief 和 Pandas 本质上都是 APL 的后代。没多少人意识到这一点，但 APL 的子语言之一是 J。J 影响了韦斯·麦金尼（Wes McKinney）
when he was at AQR, who is the author of Pandas, and then Pandas has basically inspired KDF. So these, it all leads back to, everything leads back to APL. Take a shot at eggnog. And then, yeah, this podcast,
当他在 AQR 时，他是 Pandas 的作者，然后 Pandas 基本上启发了 KDF。所以这一切都追溯到，一切都追溯到 APL。喝一杯蛋酒庆祝一下。然后，是的，这个播客，
there's a bunch of projects that I want to work on. Talks are going to, I'm probably going to try and give less talks this year uh because it took up that's funny i'm probably gonna give more talks this year i didn't give a lot of talks this year i was like you know what i'm at home pandemic i can be a little bit lazy yeah i was i gave a lot of talks last year um and also to a lot of like unique talks meaning i didn't give the same talk uh repeatedly which probably would have been would have saved me um wouldn't have caused as much work it was awesome but i think i'm just a little burnt out on on giving talks
还有一堆我想做的项目。关于演讲，我今年可能会尝试少做一些演讲，因为这占用了……这很有趣，我今年可能会做更多的演讲。我今年没有做很多演讲，我当时想，你知道吗，我在家隔离，处于大流行中，我可以稍微偷懒一下。是的，我去年做了很多演讲，而且做了很多独特的演讲，这意味着我没有重复做同一个演讲，这本可以省下我不少力气，本不会引起那么大的工作量。这很棒，但我想我对做演讲有点精疲力竭了。
um and i'm sure that'll change in two weeks and then i'll want to give another one and then also yeah iso c another one. And then also, yeah, ISO C++ ranges involved there. And then potentially, depending on what's getting prioritized, there could be some other ISO C++ stuff. So, yeah, there's a lot of stuff. A lot of stuff. What are you excited about? I think the things that I'm most excited about,
而且我确信两周后这就会改变，然后我又会想做另一个演讲，还有 ISO C++ 的 ranges 也在其中。接着可能还会有其他一些 ISO C++ 的内容，取决于优先级的安排。所以，是的，有很多事情。有很多事情。你对什么感到兴奋？我想我最兴奋的事情是，
I can't say anything about for the next two to three months, but I'm going to be giving some talks, announcing some exciting stuff at NVIDIA's conference this year. But in terms of things that I can talk about, this is sort of the year where we'll finalize features for C++ 23. Now, that sounds maybe a little surprising because, like, isn't 23 a few years away but you know we have to do all of the design work um uh pretty early on the major features so that we can then work out all the bugs so by the end of this year you know it'll be the end of 2021 um and uh we want to have all of the major features together because sometime in 2022, we want to send out a committee draft of the standard where we can get a bunch of feedback and identify any bugs in it.
在接下来的两三个月里我什么都不能说，但我将在今年英伟达的会议上发表一些演讲，并宣布一些令人兴奋的事情。但就我可以公开谈论的内容而言，今年将是最终确定 C++ 23 特性的一年。现在，这听起来可能有点令人惊讶，因为，比如，23 年不是还要过几年吗？但你知道，我们必须在早期就完成所有主要特性的设计工作，以便我们能够解决所有 Bug。所以在今年年底，也就是 2021 年底，我们希望把所有主要特性都敲定，因为在 2022 年的某个时候，我们希望发出该标准的委员会草案，以便我们能够获得大量反馈并找出其中的任何 Bug。
So we really need to, by the end of this year, by this time next year, have finalized all of the major library features. The two big ones that we're working on are C++ Executors, which is an abstraction for expressing parallel work to be executed and dependencies and chains and graphs of work and separating that away from what particular type of resource is going to run that work. And then the other big thing that's in the pipeline is the C++ networking proposal. And then we also have a goal of trying to come up with a plan for what a modular standard library will look like in landing library support for co-routines. I'm not certain that we'll be able to achieve all those goals. You know, COVID has slowed down our progress a bit, but I'm fairly hopeful that we'll be able to at least land executors,
所以我们真的需要在今年年底，也就是明年的这个时候，最终确定所有主要的库特性。我们正在开发的两个大项目是 C++ 协程（Executors），它是一种用于表达要执行的并行工作以及依赖项、链条和工作图的抽象，并将其与运行该工作的特定资源类型分离开来。另一个在筹备中的重大项目是 C++ 网络提案。此外，我们的目标是为模块化标准库制定一个规划，并在标准库中加入对协程的支持。我不确定我们是否能够实现所有这些目标。你知道，新冠疫情放慢了我们的进度，但我相当乐观地认为，我们至少能够落实执行器（executors），
and if not landed in 23, that we'll be able to put out at the very least technical specification in 2022 or 2023. So I think that's probably the work that I'm most excited about in the standards world for the next year. And yeah, I think that's pretty much it. There's some other things, but as I said, I can't spoil the secret quite yet. There's several things we can't talk about. But in the future, all will be revealed. And yeah, it's an exciting time. In the midst of working remotely and not being able to meet in person, it's still awesome that there's great work being done on our day-to-day jobs at NVIDIA,
如果不能在 23 年落地，我们至少能在 2022 年或 2023 年发布技术规范。所以我认为这可能是明年标准领域里让我最兴奋的工作。是的，差不多就是这样。还有一些其他事情，但正如我所说，我还不能剧透。有几件事我们不能谈论。但在未来，一切都会水落石出。是的，这是一个激动人心的时刻。在远程办公且无法面对面开会的情况下，我们在英伟达的日常工作依然取得了巨大的进展，这真的很棒，
but also sort of in the broader scope of C++ and the ISO committee. And then also, whether it's meetups or podcasts, a lot of podcasts that are coming out. I don't know what happened, but now there's been... Well, we started a podcast and everybody wanted to be like us. Can we say that? We weren't actually technically, I think, much to your chagrin. J.F. and retroactively um copied our idea
同时在 C++ 和 ISO 委员会的更广泛范围内也是如此。不管是线上聚会还是播客，都有很多播客正在推出。我不知道发生了什么，但现在已经……好吧，我们开办了一个播客，然后每个人都想变得和我们一样。我们能这么说吗？事实上，技术上讲，可能让你感到懊恼的是，J.F. 和 Retroactively 追溯性地复制了我们的创意。
how did they do that time travel time travel so they the only the only way that they got their episode out first uh was because of time travel that's correct that's correct i see so we were the first of the new podcasts that is that is right well see and like i said i learned something every episode um we'll we'll link the uh so for those that don't know so there's uh jf and chris's podcast tlb hit um ndr no diagnostic required is a new uh c++ news focus podcast i don't even know about that one i learned something new yeah yeah so there's there's no who's running that one that's um anastasia kosakova kosakova i'm probably
他们是怎么做到的？时间旅行！时间旅行！所以他们唯一能让他们的单集节目先播出的方法……就是通过时间旅行。没-错，没-错。我明白了。所以我们是新播客里的第一家，确实如此。好吧，看，正如我所说，我每期节目都能学到新东西……我们会把链接放出来……对于那些不知道的人来说，这里有 J.F. 和 Chris 的播客 TLB Hit，NDR（No Diagnostic Required）是一个新推出的专注于 C++ 资讯的播客。我甚至都不知道那个。我学到了新东西。是的，是的。那么是谁在主持那个？那是阿纳斯塔西娅·科萨科娃（Anastasia Kozakova），我可能
pronouncing that name the last name incorrectly um and then uh phil nash of jetbrain so it's one of the jetbrains podcasts they have a bunch of them i gotta give jetbrains a shout out. I was recently, I needed to answer a question about like the C++ community. It was about like what build systems and IDEs are popular. And I was able to use the JetBrains developer ecosystem survey to like get that answer for like the past like three or four years like they do jet brains does every year this um very impressive and like professionally done survey of uh developer ecosystems in the c++ community and then they like publish all the results like they could just have chosen not to do that um and just been like yeah we'll pay this money we'll put the survey together and then we'll you know, we're not going to share it with anybody because why would we? It's like this thing that we spent resources on. But no, they like publish it, which I think is super awesome. So a big shout out to JetBrains for that. The survey is, it's called the JetBrains
把这个姓氏的发音读错了。然后还有 JetBrains 的菲尔·纳什（Phil Nash），这是 JetBrains 的播客之一，他们有一堆这样的播客。我得给 JetBrains 点个赞。我最近需要回答一个关于 C++ 社区的问题。关于哪些构建系统和 IDE 很受欢迎。我能够使用 JetBrains 开发者生态系统调查来获得过去三四年的答案，就像 JetBrains 每年所做的那样，这是一项非常令人印象深刻且专业制作的关于 C++ 社区开发者生态系统的调查，然后他们会公布所有的结果。他们本可以选择不这样做，大可说：“好吧，我们花这笔钱，把调查做出来，然后你知道的，我们不会和任何人分享，因为为什么要分享呢？这是我们投入了资源的东西。”但没有，他们把它公开了，我认为这超级棒。所以向 JetBrains 致以大大的敬意。这项调查被称为 JetBrains
Developer Ecosystem Survey. And I think it's got some really useful data in it. Not only do they publish all the data, they also publish their methodology. And it's very clear that they didn't just have somebody go and throw together a SurveyMonkey survey and distribute it to a bunch of people. They put some thought into this. Yeah, I'll definitely link that in the show notes as well. So yeah, I think now technically there are, at least on my radar, three C++ specific. There's the CppCast, CppChat, and NDR. And then there's now this second layer of developers in the C++ ecosystem that have launched their different flavors of podcasts, which is TLB Hit, our podcast um and now uh the new podcast that i just listened to the episode zero last night um was uh the twos compliment podcast which is hosted by matt gobbalt of compiler explorer and
开发者生态系统调查。我认为它包含一些非常有用的数据。他们不仅公布了所有数据，还公布了他们的研究方法。很明显，他们不只是随便找个人在 SurveyMonkey 上弄个问卷然后发给一堆人。他们为此进行过深入的思考。是的，我绝对也会把链接放到节目shownotes里。所以，是的，我认为现在技术上讲，至少在我关注的范围内，有三个专注于 C++ 的播客：CppCast、CppChat 和 NDR。然后现在 C++ 生态系统中还有第二层开发者推出了他们自己不同风格的播客，也就是 TLB Hit、我们的播客，以及现在……我昨晚刚听了第 0 集的新播客，即 Two's Complement 播客，由 Compiler Explorer 的马特·戈博尔特（Matt Godbolt）主持，
an individual who i was not familiar with ben rady who i think has given a bunch of at least it sounds like from episode zero a bunch of uh talks on testing um and there's i can't actually tell what they're they're the theme of their website is like a game development um sort of looks like a retro arcade uh but their whole first episode was on testing so i'm i'm not sure if it's going to be sort of random musings like ours is where it's just them talking about whatever they want uh sure if it's going to be sort of random musings like ours is where it's just them talking about whatever they want uh or if it's going to be game focused but um i mean i love podcasts so the more podcasts the better the merrier it kind of kind of reminds me of like you know a few years ago there were just like two c++ conferences c++ now oh sorry three c++ conferences
以及一位我不太熟悉的个人，本·拉迪（Ben Rady），从第 0 集听起来，他似乎发表过一堆关于测试的演讲。我实际上看不出他们的网站主题是什么，看起来有点像复古街机游戏开发，但他们的整个第一集都是关于测试的。所以我不太确定它会像我们的节目那样是随意的闲聊，也就是他们谈论任何他们想谈论的话题，还是会专注于游戏领域。不过，我是说，我喜欢播客，所以播客越多越好，越多越热闹。这有点让我想起，你知道的，几年前只有两个 C++ 会议：C++ Now，哦抱歉，三个 C++ 会议——
c++ now cpp con and Meeting C++, and then suddenly there was an explosion. Same thing's happening with podcasts. Yeah, there's another thing to be very, very grateful for, you know, in our 2020 retro slash Fortran episode, is that as C++ developers, we are absolutely spoiled uh content in the form of conference talks and podcasts like uh as much as i am an apl fan um there is not a cornucopia of like apl talks and podcasts that i can go listen to and like pick my favorite um There's not even a single APL podcast. And there is an APL YouTube channel with talks from the Dialogue conference
C++ Now、CppCon 和 Meeting C++，然后突然之间就爆发了。播客也发生了同样的事情。是的，还有一件事非常非常值得我们在 2020 年回顾/Fortran 特辑中感恩，那就是作为 C++ 开发者，我们在会议演讲和播客等内容方面被严重宠坏了。尽管我是 APL 的超级粉丝，但并没有大量的 APL 演讲和播客供我去收听并挑选我最喜欢的。甚至连一个 APL 播客都没有。虽然有一个 APL YouTube 频道，里面有 Dialogue 会议的演讲，
that happens once a year. But even for a language like Rust, I think there's a handful of Rust conferences and they typically only last one or two days. Whereas C++ has multiple week-long conferences and just more content than you know what to do with. So as a C++ developer... Fortran has a conference now.
一年举办一次。但即使对于像 Rust 这样的语言，我想也有几个 Rust 会议，而且它们通常只持续一到两天。而 C++ 有多个为期一周的会议，内容多得让你应接不暇。所以作为一个 C++ 开发者……Fortran 现在也有会议了。
Yeah. Fortran had a conference that this was their inaugural year, although not a great year to start for an inaugural conference. But what are you going to do? It's called FortranCon. Yeah, I saw that. We'll add this to the show notes as well, but on their GitHub page, they have a repo called Talks with all of the slides and talk links linked. So yeah, if you find yourself bored
是的。Fortran 有一个会议，这是他们的首届年会，尽管作为第一届会议来说，今年并不是个好年份。但你有什么办法呢？它叫 FortranCon。是的，我看到了。我们也会把这个添加到节目shownotes中，但在他们的 GitHub 页面上，他们有一个名为 Talks 的仓库，里面链接了所有的幻灯片和演讲链接。所以，如果你发现自己很无聊，
and you're interested in either C++ or Fortran or any language, there's tons of content online. And that's where we'll end this episode. Thanks for listening and we hope you have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并且你对 C++ 或 Fortran 或任何语言感兴趣，网上有大量的资源。我们的节目就到这里。感谢收听，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。